meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
herzlich willkommen zum Medientermin
Vertragsunterzeichnung der
Modernisierung des 35 mm
fliegerabwehrsystems 85 durch
reheinmedall air
deffense es werden im Anschluss
Statements abgeben Frau
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
der rüstungsdirektor im
Verteidigungsministerium Generalmajor
Harald
wodosck und CEO von reheinmetall
airdeense Herr Oliver dür anschließend
an die Statements ist es möglich für
Journalistinnen und Journalisten Fragen
zu stellen im Anschluss daran wird
hinüber gewechselt zum Tisch und es
erfolgt dort dann die symbolische
Vertragsunterzeichnung Frau Ministerin
ich bitte um ihre
Worte vielen Dank sehr gehrter Herr
generalmeer wodosek sehr geehrter Herr D
sehr geehrte Generäle Kommandanten der
militärdche aus der Schweiz ist auch da
ein herzliches Willkommen generelle
Offiziere sehr geehrtes Team von
reheinetall Air Defense Division
electronic solutions sehr geehrte Damen
und
Herren großes Medieninteresse heute und
die Medien sind es nicht zuletzt auch
die uns immer wieder zeigen müssen wie
sich die Welt verändert hat wie wir in
einem sicherheitspolitischen Umfeld
Leben das sich ohne Zweifel
verschlechtert hat wenn man an den
brandhert denkt im Nahen Osten
verursacht durch den hinterhältigen
Angriff der Hamas der wieder aufgeflammt
ist Schreckensbilder jeden Tag und nach
dem Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine
mussten wir leben dass der Krieg auch
wieder nach Europa zurückgekehrt ist und
und Friede keine
Selbstverständlichkeit mehr ist das
konfrontiert uns alle mit einer neuen
Realität einer neuen Realität die von
uns verlangt den eine Stärkung der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung und auch
dass wir den Fokus auf das Kerngeschäft
des Bundesheeres richten nämlich auf die
militärische Landesverteidigung zum
Schutz der österreichischen Bevölkerung
und zur Wahrung der Souveränität der
Republik Österreich gerade die vielen
Bilder die wir sehen aus dem Nahen Osten
aus dem Ukrain Krieg die zeigen ganz
deutlich dass im Ernstfall ständig mit
Bedrohungen aus der Luft zu rechnen ist
und daher muss die österreichische
Landesverteidigung auch in diesem Fall
gut ausgerüstet sein die
fliegerabwehrtruppe sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ist ein zentraler Baustein
ein zentraler Baustellen unserer Mission
vorwärts und unseres zehnjährigen
aufbauplanes und ich freue mich dass das
Medieninteresse heute so groß ist weil
es wirklich ein großer Tag ist wir
schlagen heute für die zukünftigen
erforderlichen Fähigkeiten der
österreichischen bodengebundenen
Fliegerabwehr einen wesentlichen
Grundpfeiler ein unser derzeit
eingesetztes Waffensystem
fliegerabwehrsystem 35 mm ist ohne
Zweifel sehr zuverlässig aber es ist so
wie vieles im Bundesheer in die Jahre
gekommen daher werden wir es in den
nächsten 5 Jahren umfassend umfangreich
modifizieren um für die künftigen
Herausforderungen auf richtig
aufgestellt zu sein ja mit der Firma
reinmetall airdefense früher hieß sie ja
earlycon mit dieser Firma konnte ein
über die Jahrzehnte verlässliches
Unternehmen gefunden werden für diese
ohne Zweifel umfassende
Aufgabe was passiert nun wie wird nun
dieses fliegerabwehrsystem modernisiert
zum einen wird das ursächliche
Waffensystem zukünftig in der
Grundaufstellung aus zwei
fernbedienbaren Geschützen einer
multisensoreneinheit und einer
abgesetzten zentralen feuerleiteinheit
bestehen und zweitens werden im Zuge
dieser Beschaffung der erforderlichen
Anpassungen des systemumfeldes wie
Fahrzeugausstattung Ausbildung und
Infrastruktur an den technischen Stand
angepasst werden es ist mir wichtig zu
betonen dass gerade diese Trennung auch
einen besonderen zusätzlichen Schutz für
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten bilden
wird wir werden damit 690 Millionen Euro
ca investieren diese Investitionen
werden insbesondere an den Standorten
Zeltweg eigen im enstal langen lebenn
und anderen logistischen Einrichtungen
auf heresebene verwendet werden ein ganz
besonderes Anliegen war mir bzw uns auch
die offene Systemarchitektur des
zukünftigen Systems das bedeutet dass
nicht nur die im Bundesheer bereits
eingeführten Sensoren und Wirkmittel
eben z.B die mistrall Lenkwaffe oder
Mittel zur Abwehr von Drohnen in das
System integriert werden können sondern
es ist auch und das ist ganz wichtig die
volle
Interoperabilität in das bestehende und
das zukünftige command and control
system der österreichischen
luftstreikkräfte gegeben darüber hinaus
werden die international definierten
Schnittstellen implementiert um auch die
weiteren beschaffungsabsichten im
Bereich der bodengebundenen
Fliegerabwehr in ein österreichisches
Gesamtsystem für den aktiven Schutz
gegen Bedrohungen aus der Luft zu
gewährleisten mit dieser
Grundvoraussetzung sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren steht dem Bundesheer ein
System zur Verfügung das alle
zukünftigen Eventualitäten unterstützt
es ist mir wichtig mich zu bedanken mich
zu bedanken für die ausgezeichnete für
die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit zwischen
der Firma reheinmetall Air deffense und
meinen Dienst
stellen wir sind vorbereitet danke
vielmals fürs aufstellen vielen Dank für
die ausgezeichnete Zusammenarbeit mit
unseren
Dienststellen die auch sicherstellt dass
dieses Projekt rasch und erfolgreich
umgesetzt werden kann ich danke aber
auch ganz besonders den Dienststellen im
eigenen Haus der Generaldirektion ideale
insbesondere mit der Abteilung Vergabe
und einkaufsrecht allen unseren
Direktionen Fähigkeiten und
grundsatzplanung 246 und 5 sowie ganz
besonders der fliegerabwehrtruppe die
diesen Beschaffungsweg erst alle
gemeinsam ermöglichen Konten noch heuer
werden die ersten Geschütze in die
Schweiz zur Modifikation verleckt werden
und wir werden parallel bereits beginnen
mit den entsprechenden
Ausbildungsmaßnahmen im logistischen im
waffengattungsspezifischen Bereich damit
kann bereits
bei Auslieferung an das österreichische
Bundesheer eine unverzügliche
Einsatzbereitschaft der modifizierten
feuereinheit 35 mm gewährleistet sein ja
die erste vollfunktionsfähige
feuereinheit bei der fliegerabwehrtruppe
erwarten wir dann im Jahr
2025 und das sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das leitet den Wechsel in ein
neues Zeitalter der vernetzten
bodengebundenen und die digitalen
Fliegerabwehr ein das fliegerpataillon 2
im Zeltweg und eigen im enstal und die
Flieger abwehrchule sind die Verbände
die D mit diesem System ausgestattet
werden sehr Damen und Herren als
whrhafte Demokrat schützen wir haben mit
dem landesverte Schützen wir haben mit
dem
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
und mit unserem Aufbauplan einen Weg
vorgezeichnet der über diese
Legislaturperiode hinausgeht und der der
veränderten ge politischen Lage auch
Rechnung trägt wir werden somit Schritt
für Schritt zu einem modernen Bundesheer
wir investieren so viel wie noch nie in
den weiteren Aufbau unserer Armee ja und
daher haben wir auch vor wenigen Wochen
im Ministerrat den Weg geebnet dass ab
2027 auch
langstreckensysteme also über 50 km
beschafft werden können um den Beitrag
zu European skyschield auch
vollumfänglich erfüllen zu können und
damit die Planungen und Ergänzungen in
unserem Aufbauplan
2032 vornehmen zu können am Ende dieser
fähigkeitsentwicklung der
bodengebundenen Fliegerabwehr und in
Verbindung mit skyschild werden wir in
Österreich über ein
mehrchchichtiges
schalensystem verfügen dass einen
umfassenden Schutz gegen jegliche Art
von Bedrohungen aus der Luft
gewährleisten wird und zum Erhalt der
Souveränität Österreichs beiträgt mit
der heutigen Vertragsunterzeichnung
setzen wir als einen weiteren
Meilenstein zu einer modernen Armee zum
Erhalt und zur Weiterentwicklung der
Sicherheit unserer Heimat der Republik
Österreich danke
schön sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin
Claudia tner sehr geehrte Herr Dr Sagel
sehr geehrter Herr Tür äh hochgeehrte
ehren und Festgäste und Soldaten der
bodengebundenen Fliegerabwehr
mit dem heutigen Tag mit der
Vertragsunterzeichnung leiten wir die
Ausstattung der bodengebundenen
Fliegerabwehr für das 21 Jahrhundert als
wesentlichen Bestandteil der
Landesverteidigung Österreichs ein die
aktuellen europäischen militärischen
Herausforderungen und die angespannte
Situation am Rüstungsmarkt
unterstreichen die hohe Bedeutung dieser
Modernisierung
Modernisierungsmaßnahme und
fähigkeitserweiterung der
bodengebundenen
flüegerabwehr bei diesem Rüstungsprojekt
stellen wir gemeinsam mit der Firma
reinmetall Air deffense
vormalson krav sicher dass nicht n eine
Grundüberholung des in die Jahre
gekommenen Waffensystems auf eine
nachhaltige Art und Weise erfolgt
sondern darüber hinaus durch effiziente
Planung auch der permanente Schutz die
Frau Bundesministerin hat das bereits
erwähnt durch die alten und neuen
Systeme gewährleistet werden kann wir
werden also in einem zugum zugverfahren
die einzelnen Feinheiten z modif bringen
und gleichzeitig alte Feinheiten im
Einsatz behalten durch die Beschaffung
der Flieger des
fliegerabwehrkanonensystems 35 mm wird
in Verbindung mit dem kürzlich ebenfalls
durchgeführten Update des Fliegerabwehr
lenkwaffensystems Mistral ein vielfältig
einsetzbares fliegerabbewffnsystem im
nächstbereich für die Luftkräfte des ÖBH
bereitgestellt werden als nationaler
rüstungsdirekt ist es mir besonders
wichtig dass eine größtmögliche
Vernetzung der einzelnen Systeme
begleich zeitiger autarchie
sichergestellt werden kann die Firma
reinmetall erdefens hat mit der Lösung
der Modifikation des bestehenden
fliegerabwehrkanonensystems 35 mm diesen
Anforderungen umfassend und homogen
entsprochen mit diesem Lösungsansatz wer
werden die modifizierten feuerheiten
zukunftsorientiert in den Gesamtverband
der Luftstreitkräfte eingebunden der
luftwaffenschef ist heute bei uns und er
wird sich freuen wenn er in seinem
Verbund unter die Kalotte der longrange
Rads ein weiteres Element zum Schutz der
östchen Bevölkerung bekommen wird eine
Vielzahl weiterer Sensoren und
Wirkmittel können jederzeit integriert
betrieben werden und dennoch ist es
weiterhin möglich auch in in einem
autonomen Einsatz wirksam zu werden der
einsatzrahmen beginnt beim Schutz
kritischer Infrastruktur niedriger
Intensität bis hin zum
fliegerabwehrschutz im Falle der
militärischen
Landesverteidigung durch die
Strukturierung der zukünftigen
feereinheiten in det Teilbereiche
Geschütz Kontrolle Einheit und
Sensoreinheit sie sehen hinter uns noch
zwei Elemente wo es dann in Zukunft drei
Elemente geben wird werden die
taktischen Einsatzmöglichkeiten
erweitert und darüber hinaus der Schutz
und die durchhalte Fähigkeit der
eingesetzten Soldaten wesentlich erhöht
und dieser Schutz ist uns ein
wesentliches Anliegen gewesen und wir
haben mit reinmetall hier eine gute
Lösung gefunden mit Zulauf des Systems
bis 2028 wird die Österreich
Fliegerabwehr über ein Zukunft
orientiertes fliegerabwehrkanonensystem
35 mm verfügen vor allem für den
Objektschutz neben der eigentlichen
feuereinheit werden aber auch weitere
Investitionen im Bereich
informationsommunikationstechnologie und
der Eigenbeweglichkeit Erfolg und wenn
sie hinter sich blicken dann werden Sie
ein Fahrzeug erblicken das in Österreich
produziert worden ist in einer
deutschösterreichischen kproduktion
ebenfalls von man rennmetall nach dem
Abschluss der
Einführungsphase werden den Nutzern 20
Geschütze sechs Kontrolleinheiten und
sechs sensoreinheiten mit der gesamten
Logistik Ausbildung und Infrastruktur
zur Verfügung stellen die Produktion der
Flieger des fliegerabwehrkanonensystems
35 mm erfolgt nicht in Deutschland
sondern wird in der Schweiz erfolgen in
der Nähe von Zürich nur der
Schulterschluss zwischen den zuständigen
Stellen der verschiedenen Direktionen
und der Firma reinmetallerdefens konnte
den raschen Ablauf bis heute zur
Vertragsunterzeichnung ermöglichen also
wir haben etwa 12 Monate dafür gebraucht
das heute zur ver Bundesministerin
bereits gesagt der Dezember ist für uns
ein ein goldener Monat bei dem wir
unsere Verträge unterzeichnen durch ein
proaktives zuarbeiten der zuständigen
Techniker Planer Logistiker
Ausbildungsverantwortlichen bis hin zu
den fliegerabwehrsoldaten der Truppe
konnte dieses Projekt in diesem
Reifegrad gebracht werden diese lanen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren und diese
Motivation sind erforderlich um im
Rahmen der Mission vorwärts die die
zukünftigen Vorhaben in vorgegebenen
Rahmen umsetzen zu können ist ich
ersuche daher alle von meiner Warte als
rüstungschef aus alle mitwirkend
Dienstellen weiterhin diesen
lösungsorientierten dieser dieser
lösungsorientierten Herangehensweise zu
folgen um die realisierungsziel erfüllen
zu können sehr geehte fr
Bundesministerin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren abschließend liegt es an mir als
rüstungschef mich auch zu bedanken ich
darf mich bedanken vor allem bei der
vergabeabteilung unter der Leitung der
Frau Magistra felner Rab und des her dr
berlossnik die mit uns gemeinsam in
einer homogenen Form mit der Firma
gemeinsam die Verträge seit gebracht
haben dass wir sie heute mit gutem
Gewissen unterschreiben können ich
bedanke mich bei der
fliegerabwehrtruppe einer mein einer der
Offiziere den ich besonders kenne ist
auch heute hier der auch bereits mit der
drohenabwehr zu tun hatte für die
Zuarbeit für die homogene Zuarbeit für
die leistungsfähige Zuarbeit mein
Respekt gilt aber auch Ihnen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Firma
reinmetall für die konstruktive und
strukturierte Bearbeitung bei der
Lösungsfindung und Vertragserstellung
und
abschließend darf ich mich bei meinen
Damen und Herren bedanken dass sie in
einer homogenen zusammenführenden Weise
dieses Projekt zumindest einm zum
Vertrag geführt haben und dann in
weiterer Folge homogen weiterführen
werden und hier darf ich mich bedanken
bei Herr Brigadier Kolmann Leiter der
waffenysteme munitionsabteilung bei Herr
Oberst Schiller der Leiter heute nicht
bei uns sein kann der der weilt im
Einsatz und bei Herrn Oberst jofen die
in einer sehr guten Ort und Weise mit
Ihnen gemeinsam das Projekt bisher
betrieben haben sehr gete Frau
Bundesministerin es lebe das die
österreichische bliegabw lebe das
österreichische bundesher herzlichen
Dank sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin
Tanner hohe Generalität Werte Offiziere
Unteroffiziere und Soldaten des
Bundesheers Vertreter der Presse
Kollegen von
reimetal ein herzliches Servus auch von
meiner Seite und ich glaube ich darf das
sagen ich habe zwei Jahre hier in Wien
gearbeitet und es war eine sehr
bewegende Zeit für mich und
dementsprechend fühle ich mich heute
sehr wohl es ist mir ein großes Anliegen
Frau Bundesministerin Ihnen und Ihrem
geschätzten Team für in allerersten
Linie mal herzlich zu danken und zu
diesem Ergebnis zu gratulieren man muss
betonen dass Österreich die Gefahr von
drohen drohenschwärmen und anderen
Bedrohungen aus der Luft schon
frühzeitig erkannt hat weit vor dem
furchtbaren Krieg in der Ukraine der uns
alle woh täglich wieder erschüttert die
Nachrichten zeigen mehr als deutlich wie
unabdingbar eine moderne und effiziente
Luftabwehr ist wenn Sie erlauben möchte
ich an dieser Sterne gerne einen
Offizier der österreichischen
Luftraumüberwachung zitieren der uns
bereits im Jahre 2017 mit einer Aussage
beeindruckt hat er hat dazu mal gesagt
die aktuelle und zukünftige
Bedrohungslage aus der Luft ist die
Renaissance der bodengebundenen Flieger
Fliegerabwehr zum Glück haben wir diese
waffengartung nie aufgegeben das
bundeser hat bereits im Jahre 2017 an
der Flug fliegerabwehrchule langen
Lebern erste aber sehr wichtige Versuche
im Bereich der drohenabwehr unternommen
es folgt das Projekt zeat an welch
realir deffens teilnehmen durfte im
Rahmen von diesem Programm wurde enorm
wichtige Erkenntnisse gewonnen für die
Soldaten Planer beschaffen aber eben
auch für uns als reimmetall große
Verbesserungen und Innovationen brachten
reimertal ist überzeugt dass Österreich
europäischen Vergleich hier eine
absolute Vorreiterrolle im Bereich der
drohenabwehr eingenommen hat die
Einführung des neuen flugerabwehrsystem
skyguard Next Generation ist mehr als
nur ein Quantensprung es ist der
Eintritt in eine neue Dimension in der
Flieger und dronenabwehr basierend auf
einem bestehenden und eingeführten
Waffensystem dem 35 mm zwillingsgeschütz
konnte nun gemeinsam mit dem überaus
kompetenten Teams der Strukturplanung
der fliegerabweherschule langen lehbahn
der Luftraum überwach und Salzburg der
unterbeschaffungsabteilung WSM eine
Lösung erarbeitet werden die sämtlichen
Belangen und Anforderungen des
bundesheeren jetzt und vor allem auch in
der Zukunft gerecht wird die neuen
Geschütze können abgesetzt und vor allem
unbemannt bedient werden dies verbessert
den Schutz der Soldaten wesentlich und
erhöht die kampftsteigerung das Abfeuern
der sogenannten ahmunition ist nun
möglich V einfach gesagt ist das eine
genaue Wolke aus
subprojektilen das vor dass wir vor das
Ziel schießen welches somit durch
kinetische Energie äußerst effizient
bekämpft die Sensorik zur Detektion und
wir haben es vorher schon gehört ist die
leistungsfähige s leistungsfähigste
Sensorik die es im Moment am Markt gibt
eine außergewöhnliche Präzision erlaubt
es Ziele bereits frühzeitig zu erfassen
und zu identifizieren das Führungssystem
Skymaster ermöglicht es den Bediener ein
lokales luftklagebild zu erstellen die
GEF wungslage zu einzustufen und in
enger Koordination mit übergeordneten
Stellen eine Bekämpfung auszulösen die
einb Einbindung von mistralraketen das
haben wir auch schon gehört ist
ebenfalls möglich das ganze System ist
hochmobil und bietet im Rahmen der
militärischen Einsatzplanung die
höchstmögliche Effizienz und
Flexibilität ganz besonders im Hinblick
auf das vielzitierte ESI Programm möchte
ich hier festhalten dass Österreich
einen sehr wichtigen ersten Schritt
gemacht hat es ist oberste Priorität so
strategische und teure Raketensysteme
vor gezielten Angriffen zu schützen wir
nennen das defend die Defender Schütze
den der uns schützt
Österreich denkt aber auch schon weiter
und hat weit gediene Pläne für die
mobile fliegabwehr diese zusätzliche
Fähigkeit vollständig und integriert
vernetzt in eine vollumfängliche
Systemarchitektur wird in Zukunft die
gesamte bodengebundene Fliegerabwehr
Österreichs zu einer der modernsten in
Europa machen die Kombination von
hochmodernen verlegbaren mobilen
flugerwehrsystemen ist aus militärischer
Sicht unabdiehbar und
äußerst wichtig für die zukünftige
militärischen Operationen auch hier ist
dreetal a Defense
hochmtiviert und ich versichere Ihnen
dass wir stets ein verlässlicher Partner
sein werden sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin tannn ich wurde von
meinen mitarbeiten mehrfach und
ausdrücklich darum gebeten Ihnen unseren
höchsten Respekt für Ihr kompetentes
Team auszusprechen gemeinsam ist es uns
gelungen dieses Projekt in Rekordzeit
aufzusetzen der Herr general hat erwähnt
und so zu konzipieren dass es absolut
zukunftstauglich ist in klar
abgestimmten Terminen wurde stets
konstruktive Fortschritte erzielt eine
solche Arbeitsweise ist für mich immer
die bestmögliche und wir beurteilen
dieses Projekt Inn heute schon als
leuchturprojekt es braucht dazu aber die
notwendigen Kompetenzen Offenheit und
Transparenz all dies schafft Vertrauen
für eine gute Zusammenarbeit eine
zusammen Arbeit welche eine gewisse
Fehlerkultur auch zulässt aber die stets
lösungsorientiert und pragmatisch ist
auch die Vertragsverhandlung wurde sehr
professionell geführt hart in der Sache
aber stets fair und Respekt respektvoll
und diese Kultur und diese wertsche
schätze ich sehr in diesem Sinne und
wünsche ich uns allen dass wir diesen
Spirit weiterführen können und
herzlichen Dank noch mal für Ihr
Vertrauen vielen
Dank danke sehr jetzt nun für
Journalistinnen und Journalisten Fragen
zu stellen wenn Sie eine Frage haben
bitte heben Sie die Hand es kommt jemand
mit dem Mikrofon zu ihnen gibt es
Fragen bitte der Herr vom
ORF ja hallo Peter Unger von vom ORF
können Sie uns noch mal
erklären was wofür wir das sozusagen
einsetzen werden und was die genauen
Einsatzbereiche sein werden und was das
auch unserer Bevölkerung an ein an Mehr
an Sicherheit bringt
glaube das ist eine eine sehr wichtige
Frage die Details würde ich dann bitten
dass das der Herr Generalmajor ergst es
geht um alle Bedrohungen aus der Luft
wir haben diese Modernisierung ja
vorgesehen schon in unserem Aufbauplan
das heißt beginnen von ballistischen
Raketen über drohen Drohnen Schwärme
über auch Flugzeuge die eben unseren
Luftraum egal in welcher Reichweite auch
verletzen der letzte Schritt wie gesagt
den ich angesprochen habe ist dann die
der höheren Reichweite von mehr als 50
km wo wir dann aber erst im Jahr 2027
beginnen so wie schon angesprochen
worden ist das ist auch ein wichtiger
Schritt dass wir dann für die weiteren
Vorbereitungen das heißt Bedrohungen in
der kurzen mittleren Reichweite und
darüber hinaus in Form eines
schalensystemes einen umfassenden Schutz
haben
ja ich glaube vom Detail her ich sehe
aber der erdschief schaut so drein es
wird nichts mehr zu ergänzen notwendig
sein
danke die Frage für Sie
beantwortet gut danke gibt es sonst noch
Fragen dann danke dann kommen wir zur
symbolischen Vertragsunterzeichnung
durch Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
tner und dem CEO von Rheinmetall
adefense Herrn Oliver
dür
will jemand umbauen braucht noch jemand
Zeit
elständlich
noch danke
vielmals gut meine Damen und Herren das
beendet nun
den offiziellen Teil des Medientermin
sozusagen es besteht jetzt noch die
Möglichkeit bilateral Interviews zu
führen dazu bitte ich Sie wenn Sie daran
interessiert sind hier in den Bereich
der Geschütze zu
kommen
danke